Os presentamos a Teodoro Obiang el
dictador favorito de todos los
políticos españoles
Teodoro Obiang es el presidente de Guinea
Ecuatorial
sí, eso es un país y está aquí, es una
antigua colonia española en donde el
petróleo les sale por las orejas
por supuesto tanto él como el resto de
su familia están entre los más ricos
de toda África
sin embargo el 70 por ciento de la
población vive por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza
hay muchas razones por las que
indignarse con este hombre hoy vamos a
contartelas.  "yo diría es que en este
país no hay pobreza, habría lo que yo
califico como penuria"
Produce 346 mil barriles de
petróleo al día, su producto interior
brutoper cápita es el más alto de
toda África y estaría cerca de países
como Portugal, Lituania o Corea del Sur.
Exactamente Alberto para que no lo sepa
Guinea Ecuatorial fue una provincia de
España hasta 1968 "es muy lejos de
España es en las selvas de África bajo
los cielos blanquecinos del ecuador
donde la guardia colonial presta
servicio al pie de las banderas"
por eso es el único país africano
donde la lengua oficial es el español
durante las décadas posteriores
los guineanos subsistían exportando
cacao, café y frutas tropicales. En el
año 1996 se realizarón las primeras
extracciones de petróleo en el país
desde entonces su economía no ha dejado
de crecer. Sin embargo en Guinea
Ecuatorial el 70% de la población vive
bajo el umbral de la pobreza ¿por qué? La
respuesta tiene un nombre: Teodoro Obiang
"bueno no, puedo certificar la posición
de las organizaciones internacionales"
Teodoro Obiang llegó al poder
cargandose al que era por aquel entonces
el presidente de Guinea, Francisco
Macías, un sanguinario reconocido
admirador de Hitler, que casualmente
además era su tío. "Entre comillas,
libertad de expresión".
Desde entonces, desde 1979, Teodoro
Obiang lleva ostentando el cargo de
presidente de Guinea ininterrumpidamente
eso le hace ser en la actualidad el
presidente que más tiempo llevan el
cargo: 36 años.
Durante este tiempo a Obiang no le ha
temblado el pulso para ejercer una
tremenda represión policial contra sus
adversarios políticos. "Se prefiere que
alguno mate antes de hablar de política."
La prisión de playa negra, en la isla
de bioko es una de las más terribles
del mundo.
Los casos de torturas se cuentan por
miles, a los presos políticos se les
cuelga por los tobillos durante horas y
se les niega todo tipo de cuidado
médico "con la flecha descargo
seriamente aunque me hayan dado la espalda, yo solo
apunto detras fuertemente y bang ese no sale
de ahí". Aunque Guinea celebre elecciones
lo cierto es que en la práctica es una feroz
dictadura: Obiang no ha obtenido menos
del 90 por ciento del respaldo de los
votos
cada vez que se ha presentado. "Yo creo
que no sé si el hecho de que haya un
dirigente longevo en el poder es lo que
llaman dictadura pero nosotros tenemos
la aceptación del pueblo de Guinea
Ecuatorial, nosotros tenemos la
aceptación del pueblo de Guinea Ecuatorial"
La familia de Obiang guarda una fortuna
al exterior que puede ascender a miles
de millones de dólares
sólo en Estados Unidos la justicia
localizó una cuenta en el banco riggs
de Nueva York con 700 millones de
dólares procedentes del petróleo.
Mientras Teodoro Obiang se gasta 55
millones de dólares en un boeing 737
con baños de oro, en en Guinea Ecuatorial  la
gente vive con menos de dos dólares al
día.
Muchos viven en barrios de chabolas como este. Esta mujer asegura
llevar varios días sin agua corriente
sin  embargo no se atreve a
hablarle a la cámara. Sin embargo la
estrella de la familia
es Teodorin, uno de las 42 hijos
reconocidos de Teodoro Obiang
Teodorín habría llegado a tener un patrimonio
de 300 millones de dólares en Estados
Unidos, que incluía treintados coches
deportivos, una mansión en Malibú y
cerca de dos millones de dólares en
objetos de coleccionista de Michael
Jackson
y es que además presume de ese nivel de
vida en redes como Instagram donde
periódicamente comparte públicamente
la vida que se pega. Todos le
apuntan con el próximo sucesor de su
padre, actualmente ostenta el cargo de
vicepresidente.
Sin embargo, hace un par de años el
Departamento de Justicia de Estados
Unidos obligó a Teodorín a vender un
Ferrari,
la residencia que este poseía en los
Ángeles y seis estatuas de Michael Jackson a
tamaño real en una operación contra el
lavado de dinero
eso sí, el Departamento de Justicia le
permitió conservar uno de las famosas
guantes de cristales de Michael jackson.
Guinea experimentó un boom como
consecuencia del petróleo. Según el
Fondo Monetario Internacional su producto
interno bruto creció de media un 40 por
ciento al año entre 1996 y 2006
esto no tiene precedentes en la historia.
Por desgracia los guineanos no vieron
nada de este dinero mientras que su pib
per cápita es el más alto de África
tres de cada cuatro personas viven
bajo el umbral de la pobreza, las inversiones
en sanidad, educación o desarrollo institucional
no existen. En cambio Obiang destina
todos los petrodólares a faraónicos
proyectos como Oyala, una nueva ciudad
que está construyendo en la profundidad
de la selva "el doctor rodriguez nos acusó
de haber emprendido proyectos faraónicos
digo yo qué tiene de faraónico haber hecho
construir esas tres magníficas
pirámides."
Espera mover la capital del país hasta
allí para evitar posibles golpes de
estado como el de al año 2009. "La democracia no es el desorden, no es la guerra."
Actualmente la zona consta de un hotel
de lujo con 450 nuevas habitaciones y
algunos edificios vacíos en los que
ellos pretenden que se instalen
universidades internacionales.
Sin embargo la caída en el precio el
petróleo está perjudicando la
financiación de estos proyectos
megalómanos como es el caso de Oyala
"catastrófica la situación,
catastrófica, se prefiere que uno
mate antes de hablar de política".
Como veíamos en el caso de Botsuana, ésta
era un caso de éxito por sus instituciones
sin embargo en el caso de Guinea
podemos comprobar qué pasa cuando
tenemos todo lo contrario
por mucha riqueza natural que tenga un
territorio la falta de instituciones que
amparen la propiedad privada y protejan
la libertad individual hacen que un
país se convierta en el cortijo
particular unos pocos.